so my mother one time took me to get a
haircut this lady named Billy Miss Bobby
she had a male name they'd wanted her to
be a man when I met her she was probably
90. or 89 she might have been 89. she
was a barber
you know or she at least she owned the
barber clothing where I'm from if you
had the outfit bro that was it
you didn't need a diploma where I'm from
if you had overalls you farmed you might
live in an apartment but you got three
corn bushes out front and you doing corn
once a year if you owned a name tag and
it said your name on it you walk in any
damn Shoney's and just start working you
wasn't on staff it didn't matter you
walk in that you write on there
Ricky's daddy or whatever on the time
car you clock in as long as you had a
name tag then you were bam qualified
baby
that's where I'm from I think her name
was Miss Bobby so she was a haircutter
or she had the uniform
so at one point the bus driver
originally cut our hair
and he drove bus one Mr Ray was his name
and he pulled the bus over
once every couple weeks and he cut
everybody on that bet
everybody got the same cut on that
everybody something happened to him he
might have been changing a tire and got
hit by a vehicle or something you know
natural causes or whatever you know
whatever natural causes were back then
something happened to Mr Ray and so we
had to go to miss Bobby or Miss bill I
can't remember her name Bobby or Billy
and they wanted her to be a man you
could tell you sold pictures of her
they'd always her Daddy had dressed her
up like a man when she was a kid and
they wrote even you know you'd see
somebody write man man in here on her
back
you know somebody would write that on
her back and you know she'd have a
picture of her in college and somebody
written man in in here on her back I
think that might have been the original
trans with somebody just writing you
know
man in here
on her back
uh and we got it everybody got the point
you didn't have to get the sex you
didn't have to do all of that
so really saves a lot of money which I
think
that's nice you write man in here on
each arm he showed that to me when I
roll up I get it
all right Bridget I'll call you Bradley
I get it boom that's it we don't need
you know we we don't need a lot of other
Insanity around it
if you trans and out we've all everybody
damn so she was the hair cutter and I
was over there one time
and my mom would drop me off because
that old lady she was real chatty she
talked to me she damn
she talked to you by the time she got
done talking to you you know it was
she was 91 if she's 90 she's not it was
just like dang man
so she kept talking and so Mom would
drop me off there Mom would drop me off
there and uh
and I got the cut I get that trim but
one time I was in there she had a stroke
right
and she's laying on the ground with the
scissors you know and I'd never been
around somebody that had a stroke I
didn't know what it was
and so I just sat there man
you know I feel bad about it I was well
behaved but I sat there for probably
15 minutes
and I thought she was just being real
quiet or something or I don't know what
I thought
maybe she was doing hide and go seek but
she just
forgot to hide and thought she was
hiding or something I don't know what I
thought at that age but I remember just
being in that room and it was quiet as
could be
foreign
came or something
and he's like what the hell happened in
here and he called me a
sometimes I feel like a love you
feel me
sometimes I feel like three tenths of a
I never put on panties or nothing
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one